joe biden was interviewed by 60 minutes
but here's the part that i think a lot
of people are making a big deal about
when he's asked if he will run for
re-election and he doesn't exactly say
yes sir are you committed to running
again or are there certain conditions
that have to be right look if i were to
say to you i'm running again all of a
sudden a whole range of things come into
play that i have uh requirements i have
to change and move and do in terms of
elections in terms of election loss
then it's much too early to make that
kind of decision i take it the decision
has not been made in your own head
look
my intentions i said to begin with
is that i would run again but it's just
an intention but is it a firm decision
that i run again that remains to be seen
i guess a lot being made of this
especially in conservative media that
this is well he didn't say it was going
to run again i i don't see it as
anything significant he is going to run
again the only thing that would stop him
is if he
dies